[MUSIC PLAYING]
MILES BETRO: We're going to get
started, to stay on schedule.
Thank you very much for
coming here this afternoon.
Hopefully, everyone's had
a successful, productive
conference.
I had a lot of
interesting conversations
over the past week myself.
I'm Miles Betro.
I'm a Solutions
Architect with Google.
Came into Google with Orbitera.
And we're here to
talk, actually,
about Orbitera and Apigee,
two recent acquisitions
by Google Cloud.
Both of which are multi-cloud
solutions, connected platforms,
meant to really enable partner
commerce across clouds,
across different ecosystems,
across different SaaS
platforms.
And really trying
to reduce friction
and increase adoption of partner
solutions in the cloud today.
So as we go through
the presentation today,
we have an agenda.
We'll talk a little bit about
the market evolution of Cloud,
and what the implications
of that are for ISVs.
Talk a little bit about
the Orbitera platform.
Speak to the Apigee
platform, as well.
Talk about both of
their functionalities
and real purposes
in cloud commerce.
And then, talk about that
joint value proposition--
how Orbitera and Apigee
jointly, together, can
help accelerate monetizations of
different kinds of consumption
and subscription-based products
in multiple cloud environments.
And then, we're very
fortunate to be joined today
by two mutual partners
of Orbitera and Apigee.
We have some people from Pitney
Bowes, as well as from Veritas.
We're going to go through a
Pitney Bowes use case and demo
showing the potential of an
end-to-end, customer-facing
implementation of a joint
Orbitera-Apigee solution.
And then, we'll bring
up a few of the members
of those companies on
stage and have some Q&A.
So let's go right into
the market evolution.
What does it mean when ISVs
have to go into the cloud?
There's some really
important implications.
And it's much more
difficult than making sure
that your application
just runs on cloud xyz.
From the ISV side
of things, there's
more demands for the sales
motion from their customers.
Customers and
consumers in the cloud
are demanding more retail
consumer-like experiences.
Because, quite
frankly, enterprises
don't care about what's actually
making the solution run.
They just want to have it work.
Pricing models, due to that
consumer focus that the cloud
is bringing, are moving more
towards consumption-based
models--
"pay by the sip", rather
than "pay by the drink".
We're also seeing
that making sure
that ISV systems can handle the
new monetization and pricing
models in the cloud
can be difficult.
And users are really
adopting cloud marketplaces
to browse different kinds of
solutions, discover solutions.
You've probably
heard a lot this week
about different kinds
of marketplace venues
that are out there to help make
your products discoverable.
And it's not sufficient anymore
to only make yourself available
in one venue, one
infrastructure provider, even.
On the dev side, we also
see that the actual dev
process is impacted by this.
Whether you're trying to package
solutions into the cloud,
or you need cloud-based building
blocks to create your solution.
If you use that old
enterprise procurement
model, where it's not
instant and on demand,
it can elongate your
entire development cycle
and elongate your
go-to-market activities.
It also can restrict
your developers
from using the most innovative
and modern products.
So having that click-to-purchase
brings back agility.
And having consumption-based
pricing helps lower costs.
And this should overall, if
we set all of these systems
up correctly, help to make
sure that devs are not
hindered by the
inability to adapt
to quick, new,
emerging technologies.
Now, the marketplace
writ large--
I mean everyone here, you're
on day three of Google Next.
I don't need to convince you
that the cloud is some place
to be.
We all know that the
cloud is growing.
But it has some very
important implications
about where software
sales models,
and where stacks are going
to be deployed in the future.
So in 2019, according to this
research study, about 1/3
of all enterprise
applications will
be cloud-only rather
than cloud-first.
Cloud-first is still
a big move today.
The industry is evolving
extremely rapidly.
83% of IT buyers rely on
product demos and lit.
They want that consumer-driven
cloud experience.
And they want to get their
hands dirty with the solution
before they're willing to
actually go to all of the time
to architect their end-to-end
operational workflow
behind this cloud adoption.
And when they get
those demos, they
are 50% more likely to
actually adopt a solution.
The industry is
growing, as well.
These gray bars in
the right-hand chart
are showing infrastructure
spending growth on the cloud.
What's not often discussed
is those blue bars.
That's actual software
spend on the cloud.
Specifically, SaaS and
PaaS-based offerings,
most of which have
to have some kind
of consumption-based
pricing model behind them.
That software side of the curve,
lower than infrastructure.
But it's still expected to
triple over the next five
years.
This is a massive
opportunity for ISVs today.
So what does this mean?
Well, it means if
you're not a cloud ISV,
you're being disrupted by
your competition right now.
Plain and simple.
ISVs have to adapt to the
needs of their customers.
Also, in the cloud, a lot
of channel or ecosystems
have been left behind in the
direct marketplace model.
And ecosystems that
create network effects
of multiple partners,
creating multiple solutions,
are where you can get
true value and start
to drag more partner
activity, as well
as more end-customer activity.
It's a very virtuous,
self-fulfilling cycle.
In order to create
this ecosystem,
you have to automate it.
Any kind of manual process
in cloud distribution
slows things down a lot.
It's unnecessary friction.
So both Apigee and
Orbitera are really
about enabling
automation, enabling
end-to-end integration,
to create ecosystems
that create virtuous cycles
of customer satisfaction
and partner engagement.
So let's talk a little bit
about Orbitera as a product.
I heard a product manager
from one of our partners
earlier today, and
he said that Orbitera
has been talked
about it quite a bit
over the course of the week.
I'm not entirely
sure what it does,
but it seems like
if you sprinkle
a little Orbitera on it, it will
solve your billing problems.
So let's actually dig
into what Orbitera is.
Orbitera is an
e-commerce platform.
We try to bring entities on the
left, who are our customers--
and this can be
software vendors,
it can be distributors or
resellers, system integrators
that need different building
blocks to be combined
into bundled solutions, or
managed service providers that
like to layer on
their own services
on top of cloud solutions.
All of these are
different customer types
that can be enabled with
the Orbitera platform.
And with that network
effect, or the ecosystem,
where Orbitera can create what
we call an n-tier hierarchy.
We can scale an unlimited number
of tiers down, sideways, up.
And this allows for
flexible business models.
And we try to bring those
entities on the left
to their customers on the right.
And those customers on the
right might not be the end user.
From an ISV's perspective,
or distributor's perspective,
the reseller of the
product is their customer.
So they need to
enable their customer,
from that perspective, to
have a more satisfying selling
and development experience.
So the middle of
the box is really
talking about the different
Orbitera platform features.
The first row is really
our guiding principles,
where we want to
reduce friction.
We want to package and
provision different kinds
of software, cloud providers,
access to different cloud
providers, through
native cloud automation.
Whenever possible, enabling
single-click deployment.
And with a whole
host of configurable
workflows to help you scale your
business to the next billion
users.
The next three rows talk about
the different product lines
underlying Orbitera.
And you can think
of these either a la
carte or holistically.
We have some partners
who use Orbitera
mostly as a billing engine, some
who use us for a test drive,
some as a white
label marketplace.
But they can also be
used holistically.
So billing allows us to
implement subscription
or consumption-based
billing anytime
we can get programmatic
access to that subscription
or consumption information.
We have native support for
GCP, as well as for AWS,
for Microsoft Azure,
for IBM SoftLayer,
for CenturyLink Cloud, more
than a dozen SaaS applications.
We can consume any kind of
metering or consumption stream.
And then, through
our price books,
apply custom pricing to
either resellers or end users.
And wrapped around this is
Dashboard's reconciliation
and reporting tools,
that allow you
to surface to your customers
a single pane of glass,
through which they can
consume their AWS, their GCP,
their Azure, their software,
their SaaS subscriptions--
everything in one shop.
And we can deploy into
multiple cloud environments
from that one marketplace.
That leads us to the next row,
marketplaces and catalogs,
where we can enable
our partners to create
their own e-commerce
white-label storefront.
Looks and feels
like their domain,
registered on
their domain space,
and hooked up with all of the
consumption and subscription
pricing that's enabled by the
subscription management engine
underlying Orbitera.
And all of this, again,
is an n-tier hierarchy,
an n-tier architecture.
So we can enable
your channel partners
to stand up their own
white-label marketplaces,
where they don't have to worry
about the underlying technical
integrations.
Lastly, we have trials
and lead management,
also known as test drives.
And this solution, as
well, is being integrated
into multiple different
Google programs,
and is also available
on other clouds.
The thin line wrapping
this whole diagram
is speaking to Orbitera's
automation capabilities.
We want to reduce friction, not
increase systems complexity.
So we have a rich framework
of callbacks and APIs
to automate integrations with
different kinds of systems.
And ideally, that end
system is something
like Apigee, which is a unified
management platform that
provides us a single
integration point to then speak
to all of the underlying
systems within an ISV.
I'll get into that
in just a minute.
So how does Orbitera help?
We try to help you grow revenue,
accelerate sales, and optimize
operations.
Specifically, we
help you grow revenue
by enabling true
multi-cloud commerce.
When I say that, I mean that
we actually meter and deploy
into multiple clouds.
We have the big three
public clouds today--
Google Cloud, AWS, and Azure.
And we can bundle multiple
infrastructure, as well as
SaaS or license-based solutions,
into a single product that's
deployed through that
single-click framework.
And we do that through the
native provisioning services
of these different clouds.
It also helps simplify
the purchase experience,
because it's a much more
consumer-driven kind
of feel and workflow.
And through this,
you can actually
customize consumption
pricing for any end user.
It does not have to be
shared across users.
Also, we have been
able to channel
through that multi-tier
framework, where
every reseller can
have their own shingle,
their own white-label
marketplace.
They can put it on
their own domain space.
And so long as a partner has
integrated with Orbitera,
or if they have their
own solutions that
have some kind of API, or some
kind of scriptable deployment,
that reseller can inherit
those other products
from past ISVs that
have integrated with us,
or build their own solutions.
It's a completely
self-service framework.
And this really helps you
enable your partner base.
Accelerating cloud sales
is about streamlining
deployment, streamlining
access to solutions
through test drives.
And all of this is with an
eye towards automation--
integrating with your
existing CRM system
so that lead
generation is seamless,
so that your sales team can
help nurture these new leads.
And we can actually
notify you in real time
when a new lead has
accessed your test drive.
You can call them before the
environment has completed.
In terms of
optimizing operations,
this is really about automation.
If you have an API,
we can work with you.
If you don't have an API,
we can refer you to Apigee,
and then we can work with you.
I'm just kidding.
We can work with different kinds
of partner solutions, as well.
Not necessarily API-driven.
We have some partners who
are just nascently entering
the cloud.
And we have
implemented workflows
through automated
email notifications.
We've done this through
automated notifications
of different JSON endpoints.
They're totally
end-to-end APIs where
Orbitera is a silent
partner in the background.
And through our integrations
with different clouds,
we help satisfy your
end users' needs.
Because different
cloud providers
have different features
and functionalities.
It's not a bad thing.
It's not a taboo.
It's just reality.
And so your partners demand to
be able to deploy and consume
different clouds.
Orbitera helps you enable that.
So now let's talk a
little bit about Apigee.
Apigee is an API
management platform
that really helps streamline the
end-to-end digital value chain.
One of the guiding
principles of Apigee
is they have a very
opinionated view
of what APIs can and should be.
Specifically, it's not
sufficient to simply look
at things from the back-end out.
You can't slap APIs
on top of everything
and expect to have a unified
user experience, where
the user on the far
left of this slide
is being considered
from day one.
So Apigee likes
to think of things
both from an inside-out as well
as an outside-in perspective.
Because it's not just
a matter of making sure
that your devs
are building APIs.
You need to rationalize
all those APIs, make
sure your different
dev teams are using
the same kind of language.
And through that, Apigee
can be the polyglot
that does all the translations
between your different teams,
wraps all these together,
scales, secures,
and helps monetize these
different kinds of automated
systems that you're enabling.
So the Apigee platform,
or Apigee Edge,
can be seen in many
different angles.
Whether you're the
app user, you're
the operational team
monitoring and administering
the back-end, whether you're
the developers or the API
team trying to bring that
developed solution to your apps
and to your systems.
So here are some
of the principles
of Apigee that you see on
the right-hand of this slide.
Apigee is absolutely a
purpose-built, cloud-native API
management platform, with
that centralized point
of government.
Fully multi-tenant support,
just like Orbitera.
Apigee is a truly
multi-cloud platform
that can be installed in
multiple cloud environments,
and even on-prem.
Again, much like Orbitera, they
take a self-service standpoint.
Because the last
thing a partner needs
when they need nimbleness
and responsiveness is
to file a ticket with their
platform to actually make
something happen.
We want to put the
tools in your hands.
And obviously, it's about
scaling to enterprise.
And Apigee has helped
many enterprises
deliver their applications,
their services,
to millions and
millions of users.
Here's some of the flavor behind
Apigee's deep integrations
with multiple
cloud environments.
As you can see here,
Apigee, while fully
owned and integrated with
Google Cloud Platform,
has also installed
their application
in multiple other environments--
AWS, on Azure,
through Cloud Foundry,
on GCP, and Kubernetes
environments, as well.
And you can install Apigee
in an on-prem environment
to help bridge that gap between
the reality of today, where
you're not quite
yet on the cloud,
and the future, where
you want to get to.
So how do these two
platforms fit together?
Orbitera is a platform that
helps you monetize, bill,
demonstrate, and distribute
your products, your solutions.
Products can be bundles of
multiple apps or single apps.
And we help you create
ecosystems and link
partnerships together.
So if you're a distributor, you
can invite your ISV partners
to publish their products into
your distributor ecosystem.
Or if you're an ISV that
wants to enable that,
you just need to integrate
with our systems,
and you can use us as
a force multiplier.
Apigee is API
management at scale.
That allows connections between
different user experiences,
different end systems.
And if you've ever
done a cloud migration,
you know that it's real-- it can
be painful and onerous, trying
to herd the cats of all
your different APIs.
Apigee makes that process
relatively painless.
When you combine these
two platforms together,
Orbitera can act as
the unified front-end,
with billing management,
partner management,
ecosystem management
tools, as well as
all of the reporting
and analytics
that you might need, while
Apigee provides the automated,
unified management portal
that Orbitera can speak with,
and scale all of their
underlying systems
to accelerate your
go-to-market activity.
So let's go through a few
hypothetical examples.
And then, we'll talk
about a real-life example
with Pitney Bowes.
This is one example of how
Apigee and Orbitera can
help enable ISV
multi-cloud distribution.
In the top, you see Orbitera.
The visible portion
to your end users
is that white-label
e-commerce store.
But it's powered by
our billing management
engine, customer
management tools that
allow for customer-specific
pricing, or even
account-specific pricing.
We can enable test drives
on multiple cloud platforms,
and integrate with
multiple catalogs
across those different clouds.
Apigee, meanwhile, helps
provide that unified layer
that allows for a
single call into Apigee
to speak to many
underlying systems.
So here, as an example, we can
help Apigee unify payments,
ERP, accounting,
and orchestration.
Apigee secures it, scales it,
and provides a unified API
front.
Orbitera can then consume
consumption information
from Apigee, and send
orchestration calls, purchase
calls, credit calls, into
the ISV's underlying systems.
Another potential use case is
to create an app ecosystem.
So because Orbitera
interfaces with multiple cloud
environments and can
orchestrate through,
essentially, an
arbitrary API call,
we can enable an
ecosystem like this,
where the applications
are driven off
of an Orbitera-powered
marketplace.
Billing, catalog management,
as well as partner management,
by the way, and
customer management,
is tooled through the
back-end of Orbitera.
And it allows the store to
surface either first party
apps, third party apps,
or bundled solutions that
call into multiple of these.
And then, the Apigee Edge API
management platform, again,
helps us interface with all
of those myriad internal ISV
system.
So now we'll go into the actual
Pitney Bowes use case demo.
So Orbitera, Apigee, Pitney
Bowes, as well as Google,
have been collaborating
on a project
to help enable different kinds
of distribution and device--
construction and manufacturing
and distribution by the part
of Pitney Bowes.
This requires a lot of
work on the Android team
on the device side of things,
Orbitera in the marketplace app
management and partner
management side of things,
and then Apigee, making sure
that all these systems--
both third and first party--
speak to one another in
a seamless, scalable way.
Specifically, we're
collaborating to create
an Android-powered device that
helps modernize and streamline
the Pitney Bowes
shipping label machine,
and turns it into just a
shipping label machine--
or a strong, market-leading
shipping label machine,
I should say--
to a digital
distribution platform,
where they can not only fulfill
their goal of making shipping
easy, but also use it as
a monetization platform
for future distribution.
So if you look at
this diagram, I
want to first draw
your attention
to the right-hand side, the
Apigee-powered payment APIs.
Apigee provides this
unified management layer,
where they have
a billing account
API, payment transaction
API, different kinds
of reconciliation
reporting APIs,
that Orbitera can call into
on any product purchase.
So once a product
is purchased off
of this Orbitera-powered
app marketplace,
we can integrate with Apigee,
with Pitney Bowes' systems,
to instantly validate whether
they can purchase this or not,
checking their ledger account.
We'll create that
transaction in the ERP system
instantly, as well, and
establish the billing
relationship.
All on the click of Buy.
Orbitera, in the
middle, helps talk
to the Android-powered
device as well as Apigee,
and provides a partner portal,
through which Pitney Bowes'
partners can create their own
apps and solutions that can
then be distributed to
these millions and millions
of small business devices.
This includes a robust set
of governance and approvals,
so that Pitney
Bowes' admins have
complete control over
what's published and where.
We have the Android-powered
device on the left-hand side.
We've been collaborating
closely with the Android team
to create a
customized device that
sits on top of this shipping
label machine, that can then
be used by these
small businesses
to purchase new
products and services--
things like G Suite for
the small business--
right through the
shipping label machine.
Then, Orbitera itself enables
a myriad of pricing models
within this ecosystem.
You can pay by the sip,
you can pay by the drink,
you can pay by the seat.
Pay for it by the
week, month, year.
Fortnight, too, if you want.
You define the frequencies.
And all of this is then
integrated with a seamless user
experience.
Because we need to have the
user experience in mind each
and every step of the way.
And very importantly, as Pitney
looks towards the future,
Orbitera-- because of
our multi-cloud axis,
or view of the world--
allows us to then
replicate this marketplace
on to multiple devices,
not necessarily just
Android devices.
Can include Windows,
can include Web.
Other mobile devices, as well.
So now I'm going to go
through and actually
show you a live demo of the
Pitney Bowes Orbitera use case.
And we'll actually first
start with the tablet.
So this is an example of a
real, live tablet that would
be sitting on top of a device.
Think of it like
your modern copier.
Here, on the screen, we have
the Orbitera store, as well as
a couple apps that I
purchased beforehand,
given that it's a live demo.
So a user can click
on the store and see
a consumer-driven experience.
They see bundled solutions.
Here's an example of
three applications.
Two first party, Pitney
Bowes-created apps, SendPro
and the Location
Intelligence MyPro add-on.
As well as a third
party app, ShipRush.
Now, we're logged in as a user.
And I can browse
these solutions.
We make it easy for
the marketplace owner
to populate different
kinds of marketing content.
You can then allow
your users to choose
from multiple payment options
for the same base product.
And we can change
the orchestration
or parameterize any
of the user choices
here to inform how the
product is actually deployed.
I'll go ahead and choose a
small business option here.
And then we get back to
our regular consumer-driven
shopping experience.
Shopping cart, like
people are used to.
Everyone in an
enterprise is a consumer
in their personal life, so they
like this kind of approach.
Here we have purchase orders,
which are automatically
synchronized with the APIs,
or Apigee-powered payment
platform, housed
within Pitney Bowes.
So this is now, after
we click Checkout,
validating that the customer
has enough money in their ledger
account to validate
this purchase.
After we check out, the
purchase is confirmed.
And now Orbitera sends the
signal out to the mobile device
that it now has
this application.
If I now go back in, I can
click on my new SendPro product.
SendPro is now interfacing
with Apigee-powered APIs.
We have plenty of
money in our account.
I need to send some.
So I'll choose one of
my preexisting contacts.
I'll decide which
package I want to buy,
as the internet catches up.
I'll choose a flat rate box.
And remember, this is sitting
on top of an actual printing
device.
So once I confirm this
purchase, I'm ready to print.
Click that green button.
Voila, ready to ship.
Except now, Pitney Bowes
has enabled themselves
to add new products
and services over time,
invite partners to deploy
their products and solutions
into this marketplace
that's already
embedded in over 1.4 million
small businesses globally.
Now, let's pivot and
look at the actual laptop
where I'm logged into the
Apigee management platform.
Here is the Apigee Dashboard,
looking at the actual activity
underlining these apps.
Total transparency into all
activity within the ecosystem.
Product managers
love this dashboard,
because it lets them know
exactly who has been using
which app, and for how
much, whether they are
experiencing any errors or not.
Real-time visibility into
end user experiences.
We can actually look at
some of the API proxies
that are being called
underneath this live demo.
I'll look at, for example,
the shipping APIs.
Here, I'll look at the
shipping shipment API.
And as you can see
here, it says which
environments this side of
APIs has been deployed into,
and what underlying
calls are being
made within the various
internal Pitney Bowes systems
to enable this
end-to-end workflow.
So this platform now means that
Pitney Bowes no longer just
sells--
or is simply using this device
to fulfill its primary mission
of shipping labels.
It's now a distribution
platform, a digital cloud
distribution platform.
Where they can add any kind
of SaaS service, first party
applications they develop
internally, or third party
applications that they want
to bring into their ecosystem.
And we can then replicate this
process across multiple devices
in the future, whether
they're Android or not.
So you then have a
unified partner portal
to on-board different
kinds of apps and solutions
through the Orbitera platform.
And you can scale these
operations seamlessly
through Apigee.
So I'd like to now transition
back to the slides.
And I'm going to invite
several of my colleagues
up on stage now,
where we'll have
a bit of a panel discussion.
And we'll also have the
opportunity to get questions
from all of you.
Before we do that, brief
review of everything
that we've discussed today.
Getting into the cloud
requires a pivot from legacy
distribution.
Which requires thinking
about internal systems,
as well as distribution
mechanisms in the future.
And multi-cloud is
the name of the day
from enterprise consumers.
Apigee Edge is an intelligent
API management platform.
Helps to handle billions
upon billions of API
calls daily, which helps
partners scale their business.
Orbitera, meanwhile, helps
partners monetize, bill,
demonstrate, and distribute
their cloud-based solutions,
SaaS platforms, and
virtually any product
they want, into channel,
into their own ecosystem,
or into partner ecosystems.
And combined, Apigee
and Orbitera together
can help make cloud
transformations
much quicker, and less painful.
[MUSIC PLAYING]